raging wildfires are now a regular
feature of southern Europe's summer
season
but Blazers in Portugal six years ago
that killed 66 people could now bolster
a legal case aimed at forcing Nations to
speed up action to reduce emissions
six young people aged 11 to 24 are suing
32 European governments in Strasbourg
France at the European Court of Human
Rights among them Sophia Olivera if you
want to take action and show you that
you are capable to change the planet and
for the generation that is good you have
to act and respect and listen to our
voices the legal teams say the current
climate policies of those Nations will
not reduce emissions as much as required
to retain their clients quality of life
we're talking about heat extremes which
will impact their ability to exercise
live outdoors there'll be confined
indoors for significant periods of time
within their lifetime so we're talking
about concrete harm and we're talking
about emissions from across Europe
impacting them
if the six can prove those impacts
violate their human rights the
implications could be very costly for
the governments involved
the hearing today could be an
opportunity to deliver a legally binding
decision that would require governments
to act because they have failed to act
despite having the resources to adopt
more ambitious climate policies the
Court's Grand chamber is hearing several
similar cases this year
in March a group of women from
Switzerland had their own day in court
new people have it in their power to
change the course of history they argued
the Swiss governments failed to act on
climate change and so infringe their
right to life
Europe's Human Rights Convention
guarantees the court will likely rule on
both cases and a third from France at
some point next year
but as climate change and its
consequences continued to expand
similar cases in Europe and Beyond could
soon do the same villain marks Al
Jazeera
well join me now from Strasbourg is
Jerry Liston from a global legal action
Network he is the lead lawyer bringing
this case it is an extraordinary case
Jerry Liston at the largest ever climate
change case ever filed with the European
Court of Human Rights can you give us
the background a little bit of
background to the case first why did
these young Portuguese people one as
young as 11 decide to file this case
yeah thanks for having me Nick well
quite simply because they're facing a
future of unlivable heat extremes that's
what the science backed by the
governments themselves the the
international governmental panel and
climate change says about the future
that they face so they're taking what is
an unprecedented case in its scale
against all these countries actually the
most Arab countries to appear before a
court in any context ever before uh
because they're trying to compel them to
do much more to reduce their missions
which is what is necessary to safeguard
their Futures so why why to this court
in particular why not just bring the
case to the National courts in Portugal
where they live
because Portugal while it is failing uh
itself in reducing its emissions it's
responsible for only a small percentage
of uh the overall emissions of European
States we took the case against the
major emitters within Europe so we took
the EU member states as a whole and then
Russia turkey Ukraine we subsequently
were true the case against Ukraine in
light of the invasion and then
Switzerland Norway and the UK they make
up the major Invaders within Europe and
that's why we focus the case on them
it is an extraordinary challenge isn't
it taking on the legal teams of over
what 30 very very well-resourced
countries uh what will you be arguing
how are the plaintiffs impacted
yeah so we presented our arguments today
there were 86 lawyers we understand in
total there for the governments we had
are much more modest team but we
presented I think a powerful and
compelling case as to the impacts that
the applicants face this ranges from
their current experience of being
confined to their homes at times during
recent periods of extreme heat people
will be familiar with the devastating
heat waves that broke out across Europe
this summer and Portugal didn't Escape
those heat extremes but it's the future
really where the really uh extreme
impacts are predicted to occur so we're
talking about heat waves bringing
temperatures in excess of 40 degrees
that last for over a month or more in
Portugal so there even by today's
deteriorating standards they're
unimaginable in today's terms yes it's
very extreme isn't it ruling is expected
I understand in the first half of 2024
so what happens if the case is
successful what are you hoping this will
achieve
so the judgments of the European Court
of human rights are themselves legally
binding so the Judgment that we're
seeking would effectively be like a
treaty that's imposed on the 32
respondent states compelling them to do
much more to reduce their emissions not
just at home not just within their
borders but we're also saying that
states have an obligation to reduce
their contributions to emissions beyond
their borders and that includes for
example by forcing companies big
companies headquartered within their
jurisdictions to reduce their emissions
throughout their entire Global Supply
chains in line with 1.5 degrees but
would it compel them wouldn't it just
end up being up to the National courts
to enforce rulings
yes well we've seen in the National
court cases taken in Europe by climate
change so far with a striking
consistency at the European convention
on human rights being discussed by the
judges in those cases the difficulty is
they've come to very different
conclusions as to how the convention
applies and even in the most successful
cases for example there was a case by
the Dutch Supreme Court in the
well-known agenda case which led to the
court ordering the Dutch government to
do more to reduce its emissions by 2020
but even that decision if it were
replicated throughout Europe and Beyond
would be inconsistent with holding
warming to even two degrees which is
already catastrophic so what we're
looking for is a judgment that would
essentially act as a road map for
National courts that could then compel
their governments in future climate
cases taken there to reduce their
emissions in line with the amounts that
we say they must all right great to talk
to you Jerry appreciate that Jerry
Liston senior law at the global legal
action Network casely thanks very much
indeed jar thank you
thanks for having me Nick